And already this is Dr. Kevin Conner's today and I'll talk about a product that we have
in our line called appetite balancer, appetite balancer, it's a great product for a number
of reasons.
We know that excess weight is extremely common.
It can be extremely serious as it can lead to a lot of different diseases and of course
it's costly to the American population.
We're just talking about statistics in America in 2015 and 2016.
This is on the rise on an annual basis.
I won't read all this to you, you could read it, but obesity related conditions include
cancer, heart disease, stroke, just morbidity of life.
It's just not a good thing.
We all know that.
It's not like we have to be told that we need to lose weight and stop eating and drinking
sodas and things like that.
However, it's just difficult to do that, isn't it?
Because our food industry makes these things just taste so yummy so we get addicted to different
foods.
Well, you know, for years I've been telling people, lose weight, here's I've been telling
myself, lose weight.
It's more difficult than that.
We all know that.
Let's not play games.
Well, this product could help with this.
The reason why is it's formulated to help with different cravings.
It's formulated also with some things that will extremely help the main problem with weight
issues, which is the emotional problem.
We tend to eat when we're sad, we tend to eat when we're down, we eat to make us feel better
quite often.
Well, the 5HTP that's in here and the DL fetalality that's in here helps stimulate dopamine and serotonin
receptors and serotonin production.
And that helps with that piece of the craving, that's emotional piece of the craving.
So most people that I speak to are emotional eaters, they're not even eating because they're
hungry.
They're eating because they're nervous, they're something oral fixation, something to put
in their mouth, they're eating because they're bored.
Those are the kind of things that this product appetite balance will really help with.
It also has some alglutamine, the entire seed and chromium in it.
The glutamine is really beneficial to help heal the gut.
It's a low dose glutamine, so this could even be used with cancer patients on this lower
dose.
The chromium is really good to help balance the blood sugar levels, which can, you know,
with droppin blood sugar levels can cause an increase in desire for food.
So it could help balance those glucose levels in the body as well.
But the biggest benefit of this product is to help with that emotional balance, to help
to smooth that out so we're not like craving food to make us feel good.
It's not a comfort food aspect that we're eating.
Why eat so much?
I don't even know why I'm eating because I'm a great no, it's not because of that because
it just make me feel good.
Yes.
So that's what this product is for using this several times a day, three, four capsules,
multiple times a day, you'll notice you'll play with that dosage and you'll notice that
just that emotional need for putting something in your mouth will decrease.
This coupled with our leptid balancer is really a good weight loss product.
So great product to look at, check it out on our store, thanks.